вальку заважаю 21 рік вінкль йогор за
святу безневинний ніки батт а його але
дітки у сербії
жива за руку на клуб від когось педро
битки під час просто і ми буде ні в
речей можуть не сергей раптом чи помри
шкода сербія стала курилом щоб
жити залишу фарбуємо ще як раніше ми
були велику державу та владну та дні
сть щоб europass зловила на сина
оксану лазанью чому ви куди промені все
друг підручники
один з них сама повернувся з середовища та
україни у мистецтва рак одні прибрати з
локшини у кого через загоном сербських
бойовиків
бував на боті лнр четники з сербські
легко та формування кіу години другу та
світлові
а також догляд балканських воєн боровся за
волоку держав на сербію для молодих
четники в 39 особистий наймани
випорожнень дивитися викликає і сама
фото указ вбив дев'яносто дев'ятому у
батчата я в мене в руках ті самі про
перуки я взяв із собою до нової росії в
2014 це за у дружини 20 з пильовики з
сербії шию лапка i have до луганська і
клинка ж на запрошення донських козаків
шовкова
невинний своїм по ікла не поважаючи
служіння в лавах четники
пояс не ще для сербії в Росії та до
логічного і свою the movie in і пішов
добровольцем петлі матосу протесту на
сході україни пророщені манити не
маю в своєму розпорядженні його зловісний для нас розпусту
пункти братського російського народу
так ти висиш фашизму і боротьба проти аж
і фашизм у праці все ок вампір і 15 ську
символіку та воюючи проти православного
російського народу режиму проти
російського православного вальку заважати
святу вірити тим словам
для нього по засунь його як що командир
покриття н так вже по і давай вати в
україну
якщо вбили ми там члени були
алое буде потрібно безвіз ніж поїмо і
мама додивишся
сербський парламент хоче суму завалить і
ті, що відходили по видний закон тому хто
брат йому участю збійних конфліктів за
кордоном святих в'язниця теж влада
сервері кандидата пішли на офіційно
не буду Петро і мою лінію європейському
союзу
червона чує ви до помсти кру таку позицію
у час коли я наприклад штучно
сербії вас файлу тієї приїду в закон поки
сербські парламенту хвалю вас законники
і до-раю всіх хто найман син порушуючи navi
ну то з наших депутатів самі поїхали з
хіт на Україну теж засів у регіоні ці
перебуває під контролем проросійських
сил щоб буде з пустирі хоч ми на
його вигнаних вибори купу там
організовані okay supra блошиний пагорбі
лагами сербія розколота економічну
слабо окраїни хоче вступати їжу і з
небо а то сервер всищі вечора я
традиційно поблизу кисті з Росії
начальники мало що ви не радикально
радий божевільному і Петро і повз свої ідеї і
Важко від того ж саме з такою
зроблю вашу активність тих хто
повернувся із зони про те ширше
російську пропаганду провини з епосу або
напруга в Україні поважаючи болградський
політолог марку милошевич після тестер
позиція сербії досить проблематична
Євросоюз травня владно покличте ще до
українського щура а ми хочемо залишкового
на мої з замшу боці ми прив'язані їжу
росії за лижні вид російських зжирав
енергії більше частин на нашій
зовнішню тур гинули закласти як ви друзь і
так і villa is arab схильний молоді
чесний догори св виберу зрубавши на кір
естраді коли мова про плечі росію так і
нба шити мої будні сербії